[Music]
welcome back to our series on embedding
looker
previously we've given you a quick
overview of looker embedding options so
let's dive in and get you started with
our first option liquor private
embedding with this option you directly
manage the html element to embed your
looker content and your user logs into
looker separately from your host
application we will walk through these
steps we will
build the embed content url
then create the iframe
and finally enable user access
we will embed an example of looker
dashboard content at this url
instance.liquor.com
dashboards slash four
but feel free to use your own looker
content as we work through the steps
by the end of this video you should have
an iframe with your looker content
privately embedded
you will end up with this iframe code
example or something similar but first
a quick knowledge check
you should understand the iframe html
element
third-party cookies
and the parts of a url like the
parameters or hostname
[Music]
all right
let's get started let's first build the
embed content url so
what is it
if you look at the iframe code sample
the embed content url is the url set on
the iframe's source attribute
it is a modified version of your looker
content's url
let's look at our example embed content
url
the protocol must always be https and
outside of the protocol the embed
content url consists of
three parts
the host name
the path
and the parameters
let's walk through how to generate each
part of the embed content url
first let's determine the hostname
it is the same as your looker instance's
host name
so looking at the url of our example
looker content
its host name is
instance.looker.com
the embed content url's hostname is the
same hostname
instance.looker.com with the first part
of our embed content url completed
let's build the next part
the path
take your liquor content url and
identify its path with our url of our
example looker content the path is slash
dashboard slash four
then
prefix slash embed to it
and voila we have the embed content urls
path
quick caveat if you want to embed query
visualizations
check our getting started documentation
linked below
to build the embed content urls path
now with our second part of our embed
content url completed let's build the
embed content urls
parameters
these parameters control your embed
content's filtering and theming
but for now
let's just build the filter parameters
in this video navigate to your looker
content in a browser then manually
adjust the filters on your looker
content to what you want your filters to
be when your user views your embedded
content so navigating our example looker
content we will set the time frame
filter to
14 days
now look at your resulting url
you'll notice the manual filter
adjustments set parameters on the url
in this case our manual filter
adjustments automatically set the
parameter time frame equal 14 plus day
on the url
the parameter becomes the embed content
url's parameter
now when users view the embed the
embedded looker content will load with
the time frame filter automatically set
to 14 days with the parameters built
we finish building our embed content url
with our hostname
path and parameters
we have a fully formed embed content url
ready to be set on your iframe source
attribute
keep in mind
you can navigate to your embed content
url in a browser to preview your embeds
behavior and appearance also if you want
to theme and control the appearance of
your embedded looker content
check out our getting started
documentation for further details now
let's create the iframe for your looker
embedded content to go into let's say
this is your host applications dom
first insert the iframe html element
into the dom
set the iframe source attribute to the
embed content url we just built
then
define the width
the height
and other attributes you need to best
display your embedded looker content and
congrats we have now embedded liquor
content inside an iframe
but we're not done yet you need to
consider how your user will access your
looker embedded content as previously
mentioned the private embedding option
requires your user to log into looker
separately from your host application
you need to keep in mind
two things
how will you use a login
and what is your user's browser cookie
policy
first let's talk about how your user can
log into looker
if your user is not logged into licker
your iframe will show a 401 unauthorized
error screen
let's avoid that your user can log into
looker in one of two ways either your
user can log into looker on the same
browser before viewing the embedded
content
or
you can enable an optional looker login
screen inside the iframe to do this
let's augment our previously built embed
content url
with this existing parameter of time
frame equals 14 days
add the parameter
allow login screen
to the embed content urls parameters and
set it to true
now your iframe will present a looker
login screen if your user is not logged
into looker beforehand
keep in mind the login screen does come
with a couple caveats
you must disable the same origin
protections for looker login pages
setting to enable the looker login
screen in your iframe
also if your looker instance
authenticates users via single sign-on
with an identity provider
the identity provider may block the
display of its login screen in the
iframe now that we've figured out how
your user can log into liquor let's
consider your user's browser cookie
policy
liquor uses cookies for user
authentication and session storage
looking at our example embed content url
again
its hostname is instance.looker.com
now say for example your host
application url is reports.mycompany.com
myapp
its hostname is reports.mycompany.com
if your embed content url's hostname is
under a different domain from your host
application then your user's browser
must enable third-party cookies
however what if your user's browser
cannot allow third-party cookies
then you can create a custom domain for
your liquor instance so your host
application
and your looker instance
share the same domain you can find more
information on how to do this and all
these user access considerations in our
getting started documentation all right
we're done
congrats we have walked through the look
or private embedding option together we
built the embed content url created the
iframe element and enabled your users
access to the embedded content
with that we have privately embedded
liquor content in an iframe
so check out our getting started
documentation for more details on using
our private embedding option
and after that we recommend you look
into ssl embedding with the embed sdk
both
are linked in the description below look
forward to more videos in this series
where we get you started with embedding
looker see you next time
[Music]
you